desde su perspectiva que tanto puede
prosperar este proceso contra el
presidente piñera en el senado cómo
están las cargas de los partidos
políticos allí y que tanto respaldo
tiene piñera que el quedar santiago muy
buena noche de saludarte y la verdad es
que ellos un juicio político y por lo
tanto como tú bien señalaba depende de
la manera y xavi de los votos en el
senado se ha cumplido la media cama que
la cámara de diputados que ha probado la
acusación luego viene ya posterior a va
a la primera vuelta que tenemos el 21 de
noviembre la conformación de una
condición de mencionado y allí en el
senado y el oficialismo tiene la
posibilidad de poder escapar justamente
que esta cuestación fructifique dado de
que
necesitamos techo para el desarrollo de
esta acusación y no aparecer hasta los
votos en el senado para que eso suceda
de esa manera no obstante vamos a
esperar el que posterior a este 21 de
noviembre se vuelvan a generar nuevas
herramientas de lectura del senado que
podría hacer cambiar las dos actual
señor holzmann este es el segundo
intento de un juicio político o una
acusación contra el presidente piñera el
primero fue durante el estallido social
por supuestas violaciones a los derechos
humanos que tanto tiene este juicio o
estas acusaciones de tinte político como
usted lo dice a solamente unos días de
las elecciones presidenciales que
ustedes están a punto de celebrar allí
en chile
eso es una acusación y que tiene
relación con la capacidad e influencia
del presidente viniera asociado a la
compra venta de la propiedad de una
medida dominio como sea señala una
introducción y donde el funcionamiento
es que vivir lo que dice verlo cuando la
papers tiene una diversidad cuota es
nivel del pago de esa compra mienta
estaba estaba asociada a que se
aprobaran los proyectos medioambientales
cuando el reciente final iniciaba su
gobierno y es ahí donde viene el tema de
probidad y cuestionamiento respecto a
cómo actual creciente si bien no se
aprobaron nuestros proyectos en
definitiva había una intencionalidad que
estaría evidente la documentación que
está lavando lakers tiene en ese sentido
entonces landing viniera con dice
continuado por su prédica
señor holzmann en este contexto
electoral en el que está chile en este
momento la oposición ha respaldado este
tipo de acusaciones que se está jugando
la oposición en el escenario electoral
con este juicio sea que prospere o no
que tanto está en juego para ellos
lo que han logrado hasta ahora dice la
oposición para jugar a global en esta
acusación incluso con resquicio para
estableciendo un discurso más de más de
15 horas una de uno de los diputados
para el pueblo crear que llegarán los
que faltaban quitar los restringidos por
lo de cuarentena para poder producir
esta votación lo que está aquí en juego
que es el primero que creo que en el
cuestionamiento algo y nos viniera y
descargó el gobierno de piñera al
sistema económico y a la hora de
gobernar desempeñar aquí está acreditado
a más por la baja de sobre las impuestas
lo segundo es el impacto que pueda tener
la cantidad curas del centro de vista
que está asociado al pensamiento que
actualmente representa el problema de la
otra y lo tercero es poder abrir un
mayor espacio puede aquí doblar
políticos en el barrio credibilidad